parliament will put forward proposals on  how to produce healthy sustainable and  affordable food  meps are set to highlight the importance  of biodiversity reducing agriculture's  environmental impact and fair pay for  farmers  ahead of the glasgow un climate  conference meps are set to call for the  eu to take more ambitious steps to reach  carbon neutrality they'll also vote on  proposals for binding targets on  reducing methane emissions  parliament will debate the implications  of poland's constitutional tribunal  ruling which said parts of eu law were  incompatible with the country's  constitution  [Music]  following the debate in parliament on  the latest leak of the tax arrangements  of the rich and famous meps will look at  how to step up efforts to fight money  laundering and tax avoidance